I want to know why there aren't more
Republicans in Congress willing to come
forward on climate so I'm going to meet
the gops most outspoken critic
Democratic senator Sheldon Whitehouse I
am back to again urge my colleagues to
wake up to the stark reality of climate
change nearly every week for the last
four years White House has taken to the
Senate floor I am here today for now the
50th time 64th 73 I'm gonna keep doing
this I'm never going to walk away from
this issue today is my 130 107 140 fifth
time high if this is uncomfortable for
my colleagues I apologize but basically
I don't care White House pulls no
punches when it comes to calling out
Republicans they just facility wash
their hands for being the last remaining
conservative party on earth to deny the
science and climate change it is time it
is well past time like a lot of people
this situation drives me nuts that what
should not be a partisan issue has has
become a partisan issue but it really
isn't a partisan issue you've got to
look behind the partisanship and see
who's pulling the strings the truly evil
story is what the fossil fuel industry
is doing
they've taken power centers of the
Republican Party and grabbed them all
and if they pull their support from a
Republican candidate that's a very
serious threat do you see any
Republicans who want to do the right
thing on this I would say 12 to 20
Republican senators would like to be
involved in a serious piece of climate
legislation and feel they can't talking
to Republican senators about climate
change is like talking to prisoners
about escape they look around and the
whole conversation is how are we gonna
get safely over the fence or under the
fence have you got a tunnel these are
people who've got essentially a
political gun to their heads right
they're being told you do this and it's
a career ender do you see
any hope any day like their a lot what
I'm bullied by is the conversations from
Republican senators saying I know I
can't get there yet but keep doing what
you're doing what does it take to turn
them safe passage some form of safe
passage I'm amazed by what White House
is telling me despite the threat of the
fossil fuel lobby there may be enough
Republican votes in the Senate to pass a
climate bill